you
ivorie one is jariyama and chest calm
and I'm gonna play a standard game
against the Beast let's start with
Knight f3 it's been a while since I
played against the computer for
impossible so let's see how we can
approach this ok I think this will be a
good approach
oh it's c4 and I'm gonna hold off on
declaring my LightScribe bishops
intentions for just a bit not flinch
with my Center pawns just yet
and now what go at d4 g3 I don't want a
weakened d4 by playing e4
I think I've played this against the
computer before we're after d4 play
Knight f6 and Bishop f5 I think I'm
gonna go for that former pawn duo open
his eyes surprising an immediate strike
at deform
okay had humans play against this had
humans played this very move against me
but first time I'm seeing this by the
computer so block is prepared to go and
consoled I could take and then take the
Queen on this capture they're not going
to be taking with the bishop but rather
the pond I don't think there's a way to
really take advantage of the uncounseled
King position he'll find comfort on c7
c6 King c7 so I guess what we really are
looking at now is some Kings Indian
defense structure
I don't know if I want to play III e4 or
d5 I'm leaning more towards d5 and then
eform
okay let's go with this Kings Indian
defense which is maybe not a bad thing
especially against the computer playing
with some space okay well let's make
sure that I don't have to worry about
black playing e4 and probably Bishop to
e2 here yeah it should be - okay
probably Castle can't do without that
yeah mic is playing like a human guess
this is still so far so book I'm leaning
towards immediately repositioning my
night let's try this I like the idea of
stopping night h5 into f4 and also I'm
prepared to challenge a night on the B 4
C 5 squares with 93 and I don't think
that there's a good reason for me not to
immediately run in for a night d3
however mm-hmm maybe there is it does a
night on d3 would mask my Queens view of
d6 so night d3 I wonder if this is an
opportunity for black 2 and try to chip
away at the d5 point or at least open up
the Queen side son with c6 comparing
these to Bishop e3 93 Bishop e3 won't
allow c6 and the recapture with the pond
because I would win on d6 but should I
really be fearing c6 I think I'm fine
with that let's just run straight in for
a knight d3 Bishop e3 okay well I'm
pretty sure
a positional mistake a three because of
Knight takes Knight and then a four
locking down on any attempt by me to
expand on the queenside so if I really
want to expand on the queenside I'd have
to baby step it with verse B three a
three but it probably makes a bit more
sense to get another developing move in
so let's do that one of the benefits of
having my knight on d3 instead of f3 is
that I don't have to watch out for
Knight g4 having said that I guess after
I recapture black can jump there knight
in here but maybe I'm okay with that
let's develop a new piece and I maybe
I'll write with giving up my light
square bishop he is the bad bishop
certainly don't want to give this guy up
so give up him I have good harmony with
my resulting structure and bishop
okay I think it's still pretty even ish
take care yeah let's do it
and you know this idea of expanding on
the queenside I might not even have to
involve my A or B pawns can I not just
play c5 right away move that may seem a
bit counterintuitive because I'm opening
up the position when it's my opponent
who has the bishop hair however this is
this is the correct approach I'm really
never wanting to play off for here just
opens up the bishop so I'm leaning
towards playing on the side of the board
where I have space and that is the Queen
side indicated by this pawn being
positioned on black side of the board on
the Queen side another thing I could
play f3 but I'd really like to first see
black play f5 before I do this and then
it's a little bit awkward for the bishop
you'd have to go to h5 or there'd have
to be some some immediately immediate
resolution to this tension in the center
I have 5 f3 there'd have to be a capture
or a push or the bishop would have to
post up here which I don't think is
ideal I think it would much rather be on
d7 so let's let's let's go straight in
for this I like that I have the b5
square for my knight
I'm guessing I have to take right away I
don't think I can maintain the tension
so let's do it
see file open up
and now which rook to the C file
hmm none of the above can I take over
control the C file by posting my
nighttime b6 by controlling this pivot
square I may be able to eventually
double up and get into c7 hmm this is an
interesting moment
forget about which rook to play here
night a three night a 4 and to b6 is
interesting this is a base point it's
nice to have some pressure on it with a
knight I wouldn't mind seeing a knight
for Bishop Knight for light square
Bishop exchange as then I could look
towards a good versus bad bishop
situation
I really don't fear some f4 pawn a black
pawn on f4 with so much material
exchange and they're already being play
on the Queen side some open C file
shouldn't be a problem I don't think I'm
gonna be getting mated somehow some
attack against my King is this too
long-winded though Knight a 4 into b6
that's the other thing to question take
some time
you
let's give it a shot see ya see what the
computer does uh-huh
there is that as an in-betweener this
should still be all right I think my
queen is in a fine spot okay my knight
now feels out of play
after all that he feels out of play
because there's this open F file to work
with it's not just me being able to
double up and get into the seventh rank
well what this last move there is this
idea now hmm well how about Knight b6
still in 2c form let's try that I don't
think I'm missing anything around here
okay where's this bishop going could
take him out if he goes to any of these
if I go Queen d2 stopping Bishop h6
there's probably Bishop h5 striking at
this pawn um can I go up on hunting
Bishop d2 and takes a 5 mm I don't know
about that Bishop here Bishop h6 and f4
probably just have to take him out
anyway
I want a Queen trade hmm actually Queen
d2 is threatening a skewer maybe I do
like that let's try it also hitting the
pond ah some success I'd have to worry
about a dark square Bishop exchange
can I play rook d2 or yeah rook rook f2
rook takes Queen takes off for a queen
exchange I don't like that idea let's
let's try this I wouldn't mind seeing
the Queen's come off uh-huh
figured you would do that throwing a
punch at e4 fine got to defend
I maybe could have grabbed on a five
I'm sure stockfish after the game we'll
be saying what's the matter with you why
not take that pawn ah man I'm scared now
didn't see this idea that LightSquared
Bishop is on his way to Eve target e4
hmm I'm in trouble
now I want my night here supported by
pawn oh wow
I have to drop my knight back to play 2d
- I might might need to go for that I
have to secure my e4 point he can't fall
there's no way cannot allow that I
should still be alright should is the
keyword should I have the guy of these
squares covered well enough I'm gonna
exchange this rook no no no no no get
him working you goof he wasn't doing
anything now we're gonna take yeah and I
can't get to tow Queens defending that
hmm simplifying quite a bit as usual the
computer only spent a couple seconds and
every move hmm opposite are not obstacle
Bishop's playing against two bishops in
an ending huh I don't want to have the
Queen's off the board well don't have
any options there I can't play Queen
here Queen takes and then I drop you for
I don't want to allow Queen c1 I don't
think I have time for some fancy Knight
maneuver into f5 or do i Knight f1
controls c1 with the bishop I have
enough to control with the Queen and
dark square Bishop to fend off the Queen
entry I don't worry about the bishop for
the moment my concern however on Knight
f1 is Queen G form no it shouldn't be
too much of a concern complying to g3
Bishop f2 to defend the night and then
play h3
I'm gonna try for this I want to get my
knight to this weak point this whole nf5
uh-huh
so I guess preparing Queen here Knight
g3 right away h3 g4 Knight g3 into f5
Queen c4 hmm I think I want to be
prepared to jump in here right away
I don't have the time for this um I'm no
I thought you know what let's see h3 I
mean I'm still gonna try for him you
know trade and we gotta play Knight d2
or Knight g3 so I don't have time for g4
but able to get here and then play G
form if I go in here right now takes and
then this idea of push and he's a target
I should probably get my King working
some I don't think there's any oh wait a
threatening this move now my king of me
there in time minute 20 I think I need
to jump in now B fork and because
otherwise King f6 and then this is
defended h5 h4 and I'm in some trouble
I'm gonna jump in this gives them a
passed pawn a connected passed pawn if
they take but at the same time I have a
passed pawn okay
King f3 to e4 I think huh I think I
should be able to win this I have a
connected past upon his - you might as
well see it I could play g4 I'm gonna
drop this pawn actually what's wrong
with first playing Bishop c1 defend
against this push and then the capture
here yeah let's do that if they push the
pawn I could play my bishop into e3 and
then he for I wouldn't oh my goodness
can't believe I just allowed that I
should have played king of three now
push and then king here is going to
happen you have to play this I'm a king
here I have bishops III might have a
repetition I don't want that though
don't have much time
I'm gonna go for the win here no it's
you have to do this
Bishop to d4 I miscalculated
I'm losing my bishop
I'm losing my bishop I try to hold this
it's not hole double ah man I should
just play King f3
yeah I'm just floundering now I don't
have anything I just got to resign at
this point how's the bishop stopping my
pone like that just in time
okay now's a good point to resign mmm oh
man I guess I should have just played
King of three instead of Bishop to c1 oh
I was so close at least to holding a
draw
you see I didn't I didn't see this idea
of King here push and then that threat
to jump in here
kink Inc other
I have a I'm pretty sure I have a draw
at this point with just returning my
bishop no that's not clear either
because on Bishop c1 in this position
there's a bishop check and I'm not even
able to get in a position to attack the
pawn
okay I think then at this point here I
should be playing King f3
efore I think is needed takes takes and
at least I'm not losing my bishop and
I'm the one who's playing for a win here
I don't know if it's a win but I have
all my pawns on light there is a
potential target for my Bishop here
these guys and I have a connected past
pawn hmm and I've seen the computer many
times mess up these type of endings
where they have the bad fish up bad
Bishop versus a good knight or bad
Bishop versus good Bishop hmm okay so
Bishop c1 was played here g4 he's
entering now if I go King III there's
King e5 huh and I'm losing that pawn I
need you to play King f3 here instead of
the bishop backing up I wanted to have
this happen I know this is a nothing
move but I wanted to establish this King
right here first and then it buys me
some time to do some other stuff like g4
like Bishop d2 and then Bishop c3 and
then maybe go somewhere else with my
king
like approach over here get to see two
and then play b3 I don't know I maybe
maybe in the end it's still objectively
a draw but yeah Bishop c1 I guess no
good here hmm I think how the game was
played it's fine
I don't think there's too much to really
look at what the computer said a Kings
Indian defense
yeah I don't know I think I'm fine with
how I played it night a 4 was a bit I
mean what was his journey he went into
b6
c4d - hmm yeah I didn't really I didn't
really anticipate I just really didn't
see this ID of the bishop rerouting to
target e4 so I needed a I needed to
devote two pieces to defending here I
held off on that
and we got into this ending I didn't
point it out but if I'm preventing this
Queen c4 idea there is also like instead
of h3 if I'm playing b3 there's also b4
and then this idea of Queen here
offering a queen exchange hmm one of the
differences however is that that's a
pawn that could be tracked down compare
that with what they ended up having
which was AC pawn mm-hmm could I have
really hunted that pawn down never
really looked at that king over I jumped
right in
yeah as mentioned I think I do have to
jump in as otherwise King f6 h 5 h 4 and
what am i doing about efore so I jump in
now they take yeah I know I'm not going
to be there in time I'd need to access C
3 to get the pawn but there's always
this efore move hmm tough one
I'm gonna do a quick scan with stock
fish so just give me a moment and we'll
see where there's uh any good changes we
can make with this one ok let's just do
a quick check here running with stock
fish 7 to see where there's an
improvement
it's suggesting this stuff I don't
really don't see how exactly to follow
up yeah don't really see that
so I'm just playing with some space
Kings Indian defense
holding as 1/2 pond advantage
important moment I referenced this as a
positional mistake a three because of
this this it's not suggesting it I
believe it's a good move this a for move
clamping down one pond restricting to
how do I ever get c5 break in I don't
know
so instead Bishop e3
g4 yep
and it likes 94 okay
still even Knight b6 is still fine it's
liking me close to a pond advantage I
wanted to take here but isn't it better
just to play Roxie one and I play Queen
d2 first I think this is some success so
as mentioned doesn't give black know the
option to get rid of their dark square
bishop
played rook f2 this is what I was hoping
for an ending
like I guess take with the qingyao and
then I get to enter the seventh or at
least threaten to get there and he kind
of struggles the bishop struggles some
especially now that you know some work
would be needed to defend the pawn
before he goes elsewhere but I couldn't
quite manage having the Queen's off and
maintaining rook on board
so right here let's let's have a look
just at this move
I played rukka - but it's suggesting to
first capture and then well I would have
expected the rook to capture let's go
ahead and think c-4 probably this idea
to pick up the pawn at some point huh
queenie 7h3 Bishop d7 and now we go up
on grabbing oh my putting pressure on
this pawn and then we could take here
hmm suppose the rook defends this pawn
bishop b6 and it's reading close to +2
Queen c2 what's the point of Queen c2 I
don't get it looking at Queen a4 maybe
hmm yeah I really didn't I I guess my I
was distracted some by seeing the
pressure on my e4 pawn that I didn't
think to immediately keep pressure on d6
yeah really didn't enter my mind there
but I guess that was an idea now I have
to defend some on e4
yeah it's now it's just even game is
there anything missed in this endgame
doesn't like the Queen King Queen trade
but is this really enough I went into g3
Knight d2 oh that is another approach
Knight d2 within king f2 to f3 and then
grab the c4 pawn would it really be that
easy
a4
suppose King here not suggesting 83 oh
no no black plays 83
and after worried about this move okay
okay it's still saying an advantage for
me but let's just take a time out to
meet a four with a three Bishop h5
giving up upon ya suppose black just
enters we improve the King
could play here a little role reversal
and then scoop up the c4 pun hmm I was
too fixated maybe on hopping into a weak
point in blacks position on f5 instead
of a defending the pawn and be exerting
pressure on this weak point see form
which really at the time I didn't really
see it as a weak point but it is
something that's going to require the
support of a piece if it's attacked and
it could be attacked
I went in the in this direction g3
anything else missed in this ending this
will see one g4 Bishop d2 only goodness
I'm winning
oh you idiot
Bishop c3
with that move oh my goodness all I had
to do is play Bishop c3 oh that's awful
and so easy awful and so easy man they
don't have a connected past fun as soon
as this guy is pushed
bring on the King and fun ending that
should have been immediately running
through my mind as soon as this move is
played it should have been AHA should we
get into a King and pawn ending this guy
right here wins oh my goodness this is
clear so clear and just like that
it's a loss this 3738 move Bishop c3
came over what do you do
take my king is just entering
Oh Keeney five I could push because when
he drops see four is gonna drop soon you
get that pun I get this guy and soon the
c4 pawn oh that's a tough one to stomach
Bishop c3 and that's it King III and I'm
cooked
Wow I had my chance clearly okay well
tough one to stomach if I had to do it
over again I think I would revisit this
opening I think it's alright
yeah playing I get the play on the
queenside I guess this night reposition
was fine I can also look into night see
for sooner to put a media pressure on d6
instead of the rock F to move
and yeah and clearly it's not unbeatable
we know this but yeah it can miss play
these endings and I always see we saw a
huge huge shift there because right
around here it's not it's not a win so
actually the other thing the question is
what would be the the drawing idea
computers playing King f6 and this is
where I started to get a bit nervous
because I saw all the Kings gonna get
into this position but
just Bishop on c3 in here you're golden
so what is the draw I guess is the last
question to really ask what can black do
to hold a draw it's suggested Bishop f6
can you have three bishop d8 Bishop d2
so not being too quick to move this guy
maintaining this connected passed pawn
king of six g4 is in
yeah hmm Bishop III and then come around
in this direction know how much further
out it's going to take if this King
can't go too far one of these two pieces
has to watch out for this guy that's why
this is such an asset it restricts one
of the enemy pieces pawns around to stop
him he could be unleashed at any moment
not sure the point of Bishop g1 so let
me start making moves that's I don't
know I'd probably do something like this
in d1 let's just make some passing rooms
King c2 let's hold the King position
right here suppose a bishop move hmm now
I get to do this and then King here so I
think black needs to be prepared to meet
Bishop d2 Bishop d2 with bishop here
that way on king c3 there's Bishop d4
but even so this is winning because of
this
can be five can see six I could transfer
my attention I was gonna go in this
direction but my king could enter he can
make progress on the Queen side is the
short story
I didn't make the absolute best moves
what are they suggesting King e7 suppose
Bishop d2 what should black play Bishop
b6 in on King c3 the bishop revisits
here hmm okay I'm seeing I'm seeing why
the King is better on e7 it's to not
allow these bishop moves with tempo
against d6 black isn't necessarily
having to react against a threat against
d6 down the line there should be for
Bishop d4 stopping my king from entering
it's a bit tricky but clearly we see
that it's white who's trying to press
here on the Queen side and black has to
be quite accurate hmm even uh Suk's Fong
type positions like this one the King
moves over maybe I started pushing
suggesting a push here Wow getting a
little bit more complicated here but mmm
had my chances clearly Bishop c3 bring
on the King and pawn ending I have this
guy around okay tough one as usual feel
free to leave any feedback to this video
in the comment section below and as
always I hope you got something out of
it that's all for now take care bye
you